il pourrait prendre la compétence
réquisitions j'en ai pas parlé mais on
va réquisitionner faire a priori
ouais bon ça on va voir ce que fait de
normandie - j'attends j'attends avec
intérêt et beaucoup de curiosité savoir
s'il va vraiment réquisitionner des
immeubles dont on connaît dans paris où
il y en a désigné quelques-uns
qu'appartient des bons gros financiers
plateau préfèrent primer ce sont des
groupes financiers aussi que pouvait
bien juteux est bon on attend oui parce
que bon les petits proprio talent de
qu'elle ne le redirai toi tu loupes à
ton logement
on va te taxe est méchamment ça va te
coûter de l'argent parce que par contre
on a des petits malins qui garde le
relâchement vite parce qu'ils veulent le
loup et le vendre au meilleur prix au
moment ils auront envie de le louer mais
ça va être plus sur la spéculation
lourde
et puis il ya aussi la location le loup
est ce le bal à louer solidaire ou enfin
bon votre ces trucs là c'est à dire la
location qui est garanti paiement du
loyer entretiens du parc et tout et ça
c'est un truc que nous on a on a lancé
ça on a été voir ce qui se passe en
angleterre après l'incendié de l'hôtel
opéré en 2005
c'est dramatique est bon a dit mais là
ya pas assez de logements sociaux il
faut arrêter de foot les gens dans les
hôtels et aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
faut arrêter de foot les touristes dans
les logements
c'est un peu ça aussi un bon et bien là
aussi il ya une politique de la loi et
solidaires ont le bail
le solibail tout ça ça commence un peu à
prendre mais faut y aller plus quoi
parce que c'est du logement c'est mieux
de mettre une famille dans un logement
et non pas à l'hôtel et les touristes à
l'hôtel et le bailleur vie tranquille il
a son loyer qui tombe sa rente et tout
ça mais selon moi